[musique]
son agrandisseur Wagner Oui, il a fini dans
A 50 mètres d'eux, c'est vrai, c'est vrai, c'est
il a posé des mines antipersonnel
Et
c'est eux, ils les ont déjà mis, ils s'éloignaient
ils ont été remarqués par cette reconnaissance par drone et ils
ils ont été abattus à l'artillerie
[musique]
voir à ce sujet, j'ai personnellement des copines
enfance, qui a quitté Donetsk pour la Russie
ils gardent le silence à ce sujet ils comment c'est arrivé quoi
c'est arrivé, je suis généralement pour le monde, tout est comme ça
J'ai peur, j'ai pitié des gens, arrête, arrête
côtés mais je ne le fais pas mais je ne me sens pas désolé pour moi
je suis désolé pour l'homme qui est venu avec une arme
dans mon pays et j'ai tué mon mari
[musique]
la première fois que j'ai essayé d'appeler
quelque part vers quelqu'un pour me trouver personne
je n'ai rien dit le 31 au soir je
J'ai trouvé une photo sur Internet en russe
site web
Où est mon mari allongé dans une camionnette avec un jean déchiré
pied
11 4 mois
plus assis ou 60 et une amitié comme ça
[musique]
jusqu'à la fin tu ne peux pas t'en rendre compte
On dirait que tu viens de me parler hier
mec aujourd'hui il n'est plus là et accepte
cela ne peut être résolu et
apprends à vivre
[musique]